STEPHEN GREENBLATT: The area that we're standing
in London, the south bank of the Thames, was a kind of entertainment zone.
You would come here from different parts of the city,
knowing that there were lots of different things
you could do on a given afternoon.
You could pay a boatman to take you across the river on his rowboat,
drop you off here.
And then you could go to The Globe, in front of which we're standing,
or across the street to another theater, The Swan.
Or you could walk around in this area and go
to-- there were fields out beyond this zone where the theaters were.
You could practice archery.
You could go to one of the many houses of prostitution
that were in this neighborhood.
You could go to a tavern.
You might go and see what were called bull baiting
and bear baiting exhibitions at the time.
That is to say in spaces rather like this
where Londoners liked to watch a bull or a bear being attacked by savage dogs.
They found this exciting or amusing.
It was a practice that continued right up until the English Civil War
when Puritan soldiers killed most of the bears,
shot most of the bears of London.
And they never quite recovered from that.
But up until that time, all during Shakespeare's lifetime,
that was an alternative entertainment in this area.
There were lots of entertainments possible in the city
and particularly in this part of the city because it
was much less controlled by the city authorities
than the area on the other side of the river.
This area had been the center of monasteries in the Middle Ages.
And those monasteries had separate legal arrangements
from those that in the main part of the city businesses and houses had.
And that meant that certain things could be done here
that the city fathers themselves didn't much like, but that they couldn't stop.
Why did the city fathers not like the theater,
which is one of the glories of London of the time?
Well, there were lots of reasons.
They didn't like it because it was a traffic problem.
There were lots of carriages that came, people riding up on horses.
There was a legend in the seventh century
that Shakespeare got his start parking horses for people.
So he was a kind of horse parking lot attendant that everyone loved.
I don't believe it, but it's a story that
suggests that there were parking issues at the time.
And then there were problems with people taking off from work.
The city fathers, sober as they were, thought
that it was not a good idea to have a major entertainment industry that
depended on people abandoning their work and going off for the afternoon
to watch a play or to drink.
Then they were worried about prostitution.
They were worried about the possibility of people
saying things that were not somehow appropriate to be said,
that might be subversive or seditious.
And then they had the single biggest worry
that is I think something we need to take very, very seriously, which
was a public health issue.
They worried, especially about bubonic plague.
And they had good reason to worry about it.
They were all through Shakespeare's lifetime,
and for that matter before even in the year that he was born,
outbreaks, terrible outbreaks of bubonic plague
that took away the lives of very large numbers of people,
up to a third of the population of a city, of small towns and cities,
could die very, very quickly, from this extremely communicable disease.
The city didn't understand exactly-- the medical authorities
didn't exist understand exactly what the disease came from.
But they understood that it was intensified by large numbers of people
being brought together.
So they thought, OK, we're not going to tell
people they can't go to church, because after all, God should protect people
from communicable diseases that way.
But the theater, no.
So when the death rate reached a certain number in London,
the city fathers would shut the theaters down.
And they wouldn't open them again until the death
rates declined below that number.
And that happened actually periodically during Shakespeare's lifetime
and caused major problems, economic problems,
for companies like Shakespeare's and the other ones that were in competition.
They would have to figure out what to do to wile away the weeks and sometimes
months, and in one instance over a little more than a year,
before the theaters could be reopened.